outlaw king is a spiritual successor to
the classic film Braveheart and tells
the tale of how Robert the Bruce became
King of Scots the movie has a lot to
unpack from it and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down the facts that you
need to know about the film and the
events that inspired it there will be
heavy spoilers and the recently released
Netflix film is a lot better than
critics are giving it credit for so I
definitely recommend that you give it a
watch before viewing this video without
the way I'm definition and I Runet so
you don't have to outlaw King concludes
with an epic medieval bow between
England and Scotland based on the Battle
of luden Hill which took place in 1307
we see Robert the Bruce leading the
forces against King Edward and the
Prince of Wales
despite being massively outnumbered in
the range of 3000 to 600 Bruce manages
to outwit the larger army by using the
land to his advantage digging trenches
using horses as weapons and more cunning
tactics
Bruce manages to force the English and
Welsh into a retreat
Bruce was lucky that the English King
Edward died enroute to the campaign and
thus Bruce only had to face off against
the weaker Prince of Wales whom he
easily bested the film ends with Bruce
reuniting with his wife and cementing
their positions as King and Queen of
Scotland The Tale of Robert the Bruce is
something that's really close to my
heart
I come from a long line of Scottish
Bruce's and my grandfather would often
remind me that we were related to them
in some way every time Robert was
brought up where I live which is a
newcastle-upon-tyne is very near to the
border of Scotland so i felt quite
patriotic in some ways when watching
this film in a way you could say that
i'm sort of a hero myself like couldn't
you make sure you like comment and
subscribe anyway because i'm a hero
ignoring all that i actually know quite
a lot about Robert the Bruce and how the
real events that took place in this film
transpired William Wallace is the
catalyst that sets off the majority of
the events in the film and this was
mirrored in real life Wallace's
execution sparked a lot of civil unrest
amongst
the Scottish people and is what made
them rise up against the English the
Scots did triumph against the English
with their superior numbers however
unlike in the film a Bruce did not face
off against the Prince of Wales
head-to-head though the battle was a key
turning point in the Scottish rebellion
it wasn't actually the main fight and
there were several other ones that
followed with just as much weight the
Battle of Bannockburn in 1314 was far
more important in the events of the
uprising this involved the Scots taking
back an English occupied castle and once
again saw Bruce leading outnumbered
forces to victory
King Edward ii who had been newly
appointed as ruler saw this as a huge
humiliation this was actually the battle
that forced Edward to release Bruce's
wife and their reunion was due to this
and not the events in outlaw King Edward
ii was killed by his own nobles and the
final fight for Scotland's independence
happened at the negotiating table
Bruce managed to create independence for
Scotland by striking a deal with King
Edward the third after 20 years of war
the treaty was finally signed in 1328
and Bruce died the air after safe in the
knowledge that he had achieved peace and
freedom for Scotland
Bruce was laid to rest at dumb feline
Abbey and his memory still lives on
today so what are your thoughts on
outlaw King do you agree with the
critics or did you enjoy the film
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
check out my breakdown of this weekend's
other big film Overlord this is a
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]